before we start today's video i have to
let you all know that it is sponsored by
keeps
hello everyone i'm elana and welcome to
my channel where today we are back in la
finally my gosh it's nice to be back and
we are recording another q a uh if you
want to ask a question for next month's
q a because i do them every month then
leave them in the comments of this q a
excuse me i don't know what happened yes
i am back in la
uh back to my usual setup let's jump
into your questions
shall we
rob laviana said what's the best game
you played so far in 2021 so far based
on what i played my game of the year is
genuinely death's door and i really
really like it um
but uh yeah i still haven't finished it
i definitely need to especially now that
i'm back in la i feel like i have more
time to play video games and less time
stressing over visas
so definitely gonna do that but i also
really enjoyed resident evil um and this
month i'm really excited about
psychonauts 2 and about 12 minutes i'm
sure there's other stuff that's come out
this year that i forgot oh i loved
ratchet and clank as well but i feel
like
my year has been so frantic that i'm now
just sort of not even remembering what's
happened
but yeah so far it would be death's door
nss 700 said been watching hot ones
recently if you were asked on the show
how well do you think you could manage
the spice gauntlet
listen
i may have just been to central america
and gotten a tan but i
am white as [ __ ]
and i can't handle spicy food
i'm all i'm all about mayonnaise and
cheese the stereotypes are correct
no i really can't handle spicy food when
i first moved to the us uh chipotle
chicken was too hot for me so i've come
a long way since then i can do pretty
well but if i were on hot ones
i would probably [ __ ] myself
so there's that connor i said question
for you next one what has it been like
being a content creator after moving to
sony did they make you go through any
additional media training like a do say
such don't say about your wife you're
curious
um i've always worked for a large
company i've never been a solo content
creator
um
so
no it hasn't been any different to
working for anyone else ign was the most
restrictive company that i ever worked
for you know they just don't want me to
leak anything and i don't want to leak
anything either so
that's that's it uh there've been no
other
conversations um at all and i think i'm
probably more careful than they need me
to be where i have hard rules and i'm
like i just will not talk about what i
even do day to day
uh i just don't want to talk about any
of it um so yeah they've been great uh
ign was way more restrictive ign didn't
let me make certain kinds of content had
to approve certain kinds of content i
wasn't allowed to use twitch at all i
wasn't allowed to stream um
they were against me even swearing on
twitter
i wasn't allowed to talk about games or
movies on youtube so
yeah ign was uh infinitely more
restrictive you can't really get more
restrictive than what they were like
when i was working there the rules have
changed now but they were
pretty terrible chris croft said i just
saw your travel ig and love it
to use an actual camera for your
photography or just your mobile um yeah
so i just made a instagram for travel
photos because i love taking photos um
i took a photography course as part of
my
time at university because it's very
tied to journalism obviously and taking
photos was part of my job i was paid for
that
um at
multiple outlets as a journalist so i
love taking photos but i often don't
post all of them so i have tons of
travel photos that i've just never
posted
um so i just made a instagram for it
absolutely as a hobby like i do not care
if anyone follows it i'm not gonna tell
you to but if you want to
it is at leaving kanto um that's
k-a-n-t-o
and yeah i'm just gonna post probably
like one a day of a picture just to have
the nice gallery of it because i just
really enjoy doing it um but yes to
actually answer your question
christopher they're all every single
picture that will go up on there was
taken on an iphone x
uh iphone 10 i do also like using a
camera but
don't tend to want to travel with one
it's a lot easier to just carry a phone
around and having the lens swap
travel with people who do that and it
slows you down so yeah just all on an
iphone 10 i use an app called pixlr to
edit all of my photos and otherwise just
use instagram's built-in um editing
tools but i only ever do it on my phone
i don't do anything on desktop so all
the editing and picture taking is all
done
on my iphone enrique serabia said how do
you keep yourself busy at airport
airplanes since i imagine you've spent
quite a bit of time in them recently
uh i work um unsurprisingly uh
i actually have traveled a lot less
recently you know pandemic
obviously pertains to that than i did
back when i worked at ign i was
traveling like every week i was on a
flight uh back to back to back to back
to back so much travel um and i have
always uh either edited youtube videos i
usually bank them if i know that i have
a long flight i'll like record a bunch
of stuff the night before so that i have
a bunch of stuff to edit or i write
books i've written a lot of my short
stories or screenplays or books on
planes so uh yeah i also read a lot and
play a little bit of switch but i can
only maintain that for so long but yeah
generally edit youtube videos and write
daniel naggy said hi i'll have a
question for the next q a what other
game studio would you be interested in
working for in the possible future p.s i
love you content you're a strong voice
thank you outside of santa monica studio
who um
you know i always knew i would have
loved to have worked for my absolute
number one is rockstar
for the the kind of thing that i get
very inspired by as a writer but also as
a gamer that i love what they do it is
time to talk about keeps
did you know two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 and the
best way to prevent hair loss is to do
something about it while you still have
hair left that's of course
if you want to but i also love that
there's an option here for men who do
get insecure about this kind of thing
and keeps is a very convenient option
that i have verified has worked for a
number of people that i know with keeps
a licensed doctor will review your
information online and recommend the
right hair loss treatment plan for you
then your treatment is shipped directly
to your door every three months you can
message your doctor 24 7 with any
questions or concerns you may have along
the way and track your progress with
keepsa's progress tracking tool keeps
also offers generic versions of the fda
approved medication for hair loss which
makes it more affordable worth noting
that keeps treatments typically take
between four to six months to start
seeing results so it's important to act
fast basically the sooner you start
using cubes the more hair you can save
so find out why keeps has more five star
reviews than any of its competitors and
why hundreds of thousands of men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com alana pierce
or click the link in the description to
receive 50 off your first order that is
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash alana pierce
now back to the video liam g h said can
you explain australia's travel
restrictions to me why are they not
letting citizens leave that doesn't make
any sense
um
well i'm not a politician i cannot
be an accurate spokesperson for
australia
i can tell you why i suspect so for
anyone who didn't see this um or you
know missed my various blabberings about
it
australia
just recently announced that uh
citizens who
live in other countries are now
not allowed to leave so previously when
i went home i was comfortable going home
because i knew that i was automatically
exempt to be able to leave the country
because i ordinarily am a resident of
the united states uh the way australia
legally classifies me at least
very complicated that america does not
think i'm a resident
australia does so
i was always allowed to leave and i knew
that coming in where australian citizens
are actually currently not allowed to
leave and have not been for a while
without
a special exemption permit where i was
basically exempt from even needing the
exemption as it turned out so my family
currently can't come and visit me and
i was when i flew there able to leave
but now if i were to fly back they would
not let me leave i could apply for the
same exemption it's usually medical
emergency that they tend to allow for or
funerals
but very very limited and i think that i
would probably be rejected
the reason that i think they aren't
letting citizens leave is because they
are trying to prevent people from coming
and going and spreading covert i don't
think they actually care about citizens
getting out
they care about deterring citizens from
coming in
and it's worked obviously i am not going
to go home now um every other australian
that i know who is also overseas is not
planning to go back to australia now
which really sucks um it's devastating
like thinking about not knowing what i'm
going to see my family again i find to
be
very depressing um
really hard to come to terms with but
i'm now not going to go there and
there's no risk of me taking cover there
when i do go not that i did but
the next time uh that's essentially what
it is they're trying to stop us from
wanting to come home
and
successful i will not go back
so yeah i don't think it's actually they
care about people leaving it's that they
want the rules to prevent people from
wanting to come back victoria thomas
asks what was your process for growing
your hair out how long did it take slash
how often for haircuts what's your daily
haircare routine
oh my god um okay process of growing my
hair out
never tried to
never tried just kind of got long how
long did it take
didn't try uh how often for haircuts
once a year once every six months maybe
daily hair care routine um i brush twice
a day
and i just don't put any heat on it i
don't
know
how like people always tell me that
that
hair shouldn't grow this long if it's
bleached but
it just grows i'm so sorry like whenever
women ask me this sometimes i get it in
person they're like how is your hair so
blonde and so long and i'm like i don't
do anything and there was no strategy it
just
grew and i'm sorry
but i really i don't put any heat on it
i don't style it at all i just brush it
and um
sometimes i put this coconut oil stuff
in it and that's kind of nice
um but i'm sorry i don't wash it very
often either i try to wash maybe every
four days
try to prolong it so that you get the
oils through your hair that definitely
helps with the bleach part but um
there was no process or plan and i'm
sorry i can't be of any more help
where's kay said to alana when some
people return to their home country they
get commented that their accent has
changed you get any of those comments
no i literally never get told that uh my
family doesn't say it people on the
street don't say it nobody ever tells me
i sound anything other than australian
people on the internet almost every day
tell me that i don't sound australian
it's very strange when i go home
everyone's like yeah you're australian
of course you are what are you talking
about but people online all the time are
like yes you're getting american what's
happened to your accent
i don't know what that was but no not
even once have i been told that my
accent has changed jeff s said do you
have a regular hourly job you made it
sound as if you had to work on american
time like you would just have to do an
hourly job i assumed you're a full-time
streamer and writer
or were you just talking about waking up
to make phone calls at 10 meetings yes i
have a regular hourly job my job at
santa monica studio is 9 a.m to 6 p.m
those are my work hours i have some
flexibility with that i can start later
and finish later
but yes i work a regular hourly job as a
writer uh aonik said i got a question
for next up when do you get a spotify
account so we can hear your dj stuff i
want to see dj pierce stuff
all of my dj stuff is on soundcloud at
soundcloud.com and i'm actually djing
next week i'm very excited to get back
to it um
my first time like properly djing uh i
have done
two sets two empty rooms as part of
bright spot live which is like a charity
talk show thing
um but there was basically nobody there
so that doesn't quite count whereas yeah
next week i'm actually djing in front of
people for the first time since the
pandemic started i'm really really
excited about it it should be super fun
i'm not going to for this one but in the
future uh in la i might tell people
uh where i'm djing if they want to come
see but generally i try to only
advertise ones that are in the games
industry because people will be there
anyway and i try to keep like any
residencies off the internet so that i
can just enjoy it and do the job um
doesn't look great when you're supposed
to be mixing and people come up and try
and talk and then you have to talk and
then the manager or the club owner is
like the [ __ ] are you doing you're
supposed to be dj and [ __ ]
but yeah very very excited to do it
again i've really missed it it's just a
lot of fun
if you like video games you would
probably like djing it's just mixing
things at the right time it's just a
more elaborate rhythm game it's very fun
rage the promise then asks how do you
keep your motivation to work out i know
it's hard for me if i didn't have my
wife teaming up with me to get it done
i
almost feel like i plan every day around
it i'm like this i'm gonna go to the gym
at this time every morning i know when
i'm going to go to the gym and the truth
is i just really [ __ ] enjoy it i
really like weightlifting um so it's
something that i get excited to do and i
feel like it's the time where i like
just clear my head
and
just get in the zone you know and i feel
like yeah i don't know it's not a
motivation thing i just enjoy it so much
but
i think that's because i don't do cardio
which i hate like people who prep to go
to work out on a treadmill for an hour i
couldn't do that i do not have the
motivation to do that i do all of my
cardio in vr which is a ton of fun
and the gym is for weightlifting and i
just really enjoy weightlifting so it's
something that i i do really make a
priority i really think about when i'm
going to go to make sure i have the time
to go
um where that's going to fit into my day
and then i go and do it dude you just
gotta go you gotta lift some heavy [ __ ]
the doctor assistant once said my
question to you would be what makes
someone a gamer thanks
they play video
games that's it i don't care how long
for
i don't care on what platform but if you
play video games
you're a gamer son and i'm proud of you
keep it up keep up the good work
you're a gem we need you i think that is
pretty much
it
very excited to be in a country where
internet is good again let me tell you
that has been frustrating it has
definitely made my job harder
very stoked to have
reliable internet again i hope if i just
jinxed myself i swear to god
there are a lot of comments on this one
uh i've got this skit or sketch um that
i wrote about this that i should make at
some point so the last q a was called
definitely not pregnant and all these
people there's so many comments about it
being click bait
if something is spoken about in the
video and it was the first thing i spoke
about it's not click bait click bait is
when you're literally baited like a fish
meaning that
you're meant to think it's food but
actually it's a hook that's going to
[ __ ] kill you click bait is not when
something is accurate
if a headline is appealing
so it made you curious that doesn't make
it clickbait it's only clickbait if you
got tricked
and definitely not pregnant which i'm
definitely not was definitely not that
especially when it was literally the
first thing that i addressed
y'all don't know what clickbait is you
didn't get baited you were not tricked
into clicking with bait one day these
people will understand what clickbait is
i swear i'm on this tirade i stand by it
um alrighty everyone that is it for me
today videos should be up more regularly
now that i am finally back in los
angeles play watch listen is going back
to being weekly we will have a new epis
we will have a new episode up next
friday the 20th and i'm also back to
doing streams after taking a massive uh
hiatus and bailey streaming at all of
the last three months
um i actually just did stream right
before recording this video it was a
wonderful
first stream back
so thank you everyone who joined me for
that one thank you to everyone who
watched this video uh remember that if
you want to find out more about keeps
you can check out the link in the
description and otherwise i will see you
guys next time